You know, I think people like overall a
pretty nice on the highway even in la,
but sometimes they're not. Do you think
the neuro link will help that client?
Probably everybody would
be locked in together.
This hive mind tunnels will help it. We're
gonna have traffic that'll help a lot.
Yeah.
How many of those can you put in there?
Cause I was thinking about travel buddy.
That's the thing about tunnels as you
can go three d so you can go many levels,
right? So until you hit
hell yeah, but you could go,
you could have a hundred levels of
tunnel then bombs. Jesus Christ,
I don't want to be on 99 and that'll
be the 99th negative 99 floors.
Cool.
This is one of the fundamental things
people don't appreciate about tunnels is
that there's not like roads.
The fundamental issue with roads is that
do you have a tutee transport system
and a three d living and
workspace environment.
So you've got all these tall buildings
or concentrated work environments and,
and then then you want to go into
this like two of the transport system,
which is pretty low density because
cars is per spaced out pretty far.
Um, and, and so that obviously
is not going to work.
You're going to have traffic guaranteed.
But if you can go three D
on your transport system,
then you can solve all traffic and you
can either go 3-d up with a flying car or
can go through ed down with tunnels and
you can have as many tunnel levels as
you want and you can arbitrarily
relieve any amount of traffic.
You can go further down with tunnels.
Then you can go up with buildings.
You're 10,000 feet down if you want.
I wouldn't recommend it.
But what was that movie with?
What's his face? Bradley Cooper.
Not Bradley Cooper. Uh, Christian. Now
what the fuck's his name? Who is Batman?
Christian Bale, where they fought
dragons. Him and Matthew mcconaughey.
They went down deep into the
earth. How high? How deep
can we go, man? Yeah, it was,
it was that man fought dragons.
Batman.
But Reyna Reyna fire never saw that.
No Terrell but good.
I wouldn't recommend saying
bring super far down. Right.
Multan yeah.
Earth is a drawing ball of lava
with a thin crust on the top,
which we think of as like the surface,
this crust and it's mostly
just a big ball of lava.
Yeah,
that's earth. But 10,000
feet, it's not a big deal.
Have you given any consideration
whatsoever to the flat earth movement?
I think that's a trawl
situation. Oh it's not. No,
it's not. You would like to think
that because you're a super genius,
but I as a normal normal person,
I know there's people way
dumber than me and they really,
really believe they watch you two videos
which go on uninterrupted and spew out
bunch of fucking fake facts very
eloquently and articulately.
And they really believe these
people really believe. I
mean if it works for them,
I'm sure.
Fine.
It's weird that right.
That in this age where you know it was
ludicrous mode and your car goes 1.9
seconds.
Zero to 62.2 2.2 which
one's 1.9 the roaster.
The next generation roadster.
Okay. Standard edition. Yeah.
I'm on top of this shit.
That's just it.
That's just what the standard edition.
So it though about the form of
package Wa wide performance package.
What the fuck do you need a put
rocket thrusters on it for real?
What are they going to burn?
Hot Ultra high pressure.
Compressed air. Whoa. Just
cold, cold gas thrusters.
Did you have to have an air tanks? Are
they sucking the air out? Okay. Yeah.
I just have an electric pump.
Whoa.
Pump it up to like 10,000 PSI
and how fast are we talking?
Zero to 60 how fast you want to go?
I'm wanting to go. Could make it fly.
I want to go back in time can make
it fly. You make it fly. Sure.
Do you anticipate that as being I when
you were talking about the tunnels and
then flying cars, do you really
think that's going to be real,
too noisy and this too much airflow so
that the fundamental issue with flying
cars, I mean if you get work
one of those like toy drones,
I think of how much, how loud those
are and how much air that they,
how much air they blow. Now imagine if
that's like a thousand times heavier. Hmm.
This is not going to be
make her neighbors happy.
Your neighbors are not going to be happy.
If you land a flying car in your backyard,
it would be very helicopters like that
or on your roof that are just really
going to be like,
what the hell that it was annoying.
You can't even look if
you want a flying car,
just put some wheels on a helicopter.
Is there a way around that?
Like what if they figure out some sort
of magnetic technology, like all those,
Bob was our type characters were thinking
that was a part of the UFO technology.
They were doing an area 51 member.
It, didn't. They have some,
some thoughts about magnetics?
Nope. No bullshit. Yes. Really?
Yeah. It was a fundamental momentum
exchange with the air. So you must,
you must accelerate.
There's this, like this,
there's a sudden you have a mass and have
gravity, gravitational acceleration, um,
and mass mass times your
mass times gravity must equal
the massive airflow times
acceleration of that airflow
to have a neutral force.
So it's impossible and
then you won't move.
But if if mg is greater than MMA,
you will go down.
And if mas greater than mg, you
will go up. That's how it works.
There's just no way around that.
There is definitely no way around it.
There's no way to create some sort of
a magnetic something or another that
allows you to technically, yes,
you could have a strong enough magnet,
but that magnet,
it would be so strong that you
would create a lot of trouble.
We just suck cars up in new your car,
his pickup mean mean and she'd have to
repel off of either a material on the
ground or in a really nasty situation
off of Earth's gravitational field and
somehow make that incredibly light.
But that magnet would
cause so much destruction.
You'd be better off with a helicopter.
So if there was some sort of magnet road,
like you have two magnets
and they repel each other.
If you had some sort of a magnet road
that was below you and you could travel on
that magnet road, that would work. Oh
yes. Yes. You could have a magnet road, a
magnet road. Cause that's ridiculous. No,
it's work. I do that too,
right? I would not recommend it.
There's a lot of things I don't
recommend or not recommend that not good.
Not Wise, I think no roads, no, no that.
No, definitely not. Definitely not. It
was good. I would cause a lot of trouble.
So you've put some time and consideration
into this other than, you know,
instead of like my
foolishly rendered thoughts.
So you think the tunnels are the way
to do it? Oh, it'll work for sure.
That'll work. Yes. And your, these,
these tunnels that you're
building right now,
these are basically just
like test versions of this
ultimate idea that you have.
You know, it's just a
hole in the ground, right?
We played videos of it where you just,
the guys that you're going to
drop that hole in the ground,
there's a sled on it and the sled,
he goes very fast.
Like a hundred miles an hour plus. Yeah,
you can go real fast, fast as you want.
And then if you want to go long distances
you can just grow the air out of the
tunnel.
Make sure it's real straight.
Draw the air at the tunnel is head
of vacuum tunnel. Um, cause the,
and then depending on how fast you want
to go to any of these wheels or you
could use air bearings depending upon
the ambient pressure in the tunnel or you
could a maglev it if you
want to go super fast. Um,
so magnet road, yes, but
underground magnet roads,
underground manga otherwise you're going
to really create a lot of trouble with
because those metal things, so magnet
roads, the way to go just underground.
If you want to go really fast
underground you would be in a,
you would be maglev in a vacuum
tunnel mag in a vacuum tunnel.
Magnetic levitation in the back of
tunnel one with rocket launchers.
No, I would not recommend putting
any exhaust gas in the tunnel.
Oh okay. I see what you're saying.
Cause then you got to pump it on, right?
You have to pump it out and you probably
have limited amount of air in the first
place.
Like how much can you breathe?
Do you have to pump oxygen into
these cubicles to pressurize part?
It'd be like a,
like a little tiny underground space ship.
Basically like a airplane.
Cause you have a or an airplane.
It's not getting new Aaron. It is, it is,
yes. You have like a little hole. Yeah,
they have a pump. Really? Yeah. It
gets it from the outside. Yes. Wow.
I didn't know that was like,
it's the era airplanes have have it
easy because essentially you can,
they're pretty leaky. Uh, but
she's, yeah, so long as they,
as long as the air pump is working at
a decent speed, they have backup pumps,
still have like, you know, three pumps
are four pumps or something. And uh,
and then that, then
there's like, there's an x,
it exhausts through the outflow valve and,
and through whatever seals
are not sealing quite right.
Usually the door doesn't
feel quite right on a plane.
This was a bit of leakage
around the door and uh,
but the pumps,
uh,
exceed the outflow rate and then that
sets the pressure in the, in the cabin.
Now have you ever looked at
Torrance and gone, I could fix this,
but I just don't have the time.
As you make a better design for a plane,
you do a better design.
I mean,
probably, I think it is. Yeah. Oh,
who have you talked to about this?
And I've talked to
friends, friends, friends,
and your friend girlfriends
and you can tell me,
what do you got? What's
going on? Well, I mean,
the exciting thing to do would be some
sort of electric vertical takeoff and
landing supersonic jet of some kind
of vertical takeoff and landing me,
no need for a run might just
shoot up straight in the air.
Oh,
okay.
How would you do that?
Yeah,
when they do that and some
military Aircrafts, correct. Yes.
The trick is that you have, you have
to transition to level flight. Um,
and then you, the, the,
the thing that you'd use for vertical
Tafe will take off and landing is not
suitable for high speed flight.
So you have two different systems,
vary quite a lot of thought
about this quite a lot. Um, I,
the interesting thing about an electric
plane is that you want to go as high as
possible,
but you need a certain energy density
in the battery pack because you have to
have a calm gravitational
potential energy.
Once you've outcome gravitational
potential energy and you're at, at, at,
at a high altitude,
the energy use Incruse is very low and
then you can recapture a large part of
your, the gravitational potential
energy on the way down. Um,
so you really don't need any kind
of reserve fuel, if you will,
because you have the, the, the energy of
height, gravitational potential energy.
This is a lot of energy. So, so
once you can get hot at the high,
you
like,
the way to think about a plane is a
force balance to the force balance.
So a plane that is not
accelerating, um, is a,
is a neutral force balance.
Yeah, the force of gravity.
If the lift force of the wings,
then you've got the force of the,
one of a thrusting device or the,
the propeller or turbine or whatever it
is and you've got the resistance force
of the air. Now the higher you go,
the lower the air assistance. Yes,
air density drops exponentially,
but drag increases with the square
and exponential beats of square.
The higher you go, the faster you
will go for the same amount of energy
and at a certain altitude you will,
you can go supersonic
with less energy per mile,
quite a lot less energy per mile.
Then an aircraft at 35,000 feet
because it's just a force balance.
I'm just doing it for this conversation.
It makes sense though.